[Music]
three
two one action welcome back to off the
record where we talk about twitter
whatever we
want so didn't get a chance to make your
morning match in there because you
wanted to roll so quickly
starting off with an aperture
prepare june guys single serving packets
did you guys know that we got a single
serving so
you don't want to have a 10 or you need
a two go thing and you don't want to
bring your whole 10 with you because
actually the ten needs to be stored in
the refrigerator
to keep it fresh you can have a single
serving and put it into the little
bottle like that
i actually didn't know you're supposed
to put it in the fridge because then i
did a video
where are you going you're not supposed
to
well you don't know anything okay anyway
so you were making a single server yeah
i didn't know you're supposed to put it
in the fridge and then people were like
from your vlog were like
dude bart puts it in the fridge i think
you should put it in the fridge i'm like
you know who taught me uh june dan
jeremy
you just don't remember listen for [ __ ]
that's what it is we're supposed to keep
it in the fridge because it keeps it
fresh it was mind-blowing because you
know like
um all the regular teas that i have
they're like oolong or whatever so
they're like dehydrated
yeah so you store it in a cabinet but
even coffee beans you kind of like don't
you
yeah but like matcha is green and i
guess it's fresh right so like
it makes sense why you have to put it in
the fridge true how
long does it last if you don't put it in
the fridge no i do
we should know these things i would
drink the same uh since it was simple
it's like brown yeah like uh no
it's actually i've been i still have a
sip yeah
the sip canister thing has been in my
cabinet for two years and i still drink
it
yeah because we have a lot of canisters
that's why true yeah no yeah
four at our house one thing i noticed
from talking with geo or even with david
is uh i realize i know a lot of things
but if people ask more
than two why's i don't know so we
and dave were like uh you can [ __ ]
up to two questions yeah okay me and
dave were driving somewhere
and then he was like i'll tell him the
importance of multivitamins and stuff
and he goes
and then he goes oh okay cool my yeah
cause it also has prebiotics and
probiotics he goes what's prebiotic
i don't know the first question of
what's what's in the multivitamin
oh you know it has all like your your uh
fish oils your omega-3s and it has
probiotics and probiotics
you thing today's video is brought to
you by a multivitamin company that we're
going to mention later oh yeah
yeah but don't ask more than two
questions because i still won't know
can i guess what a prebiotic is i looked
it up it's like
no no okay what is it what is it i used
to know
i thought it was just fiber it is it's
fiber that helps grow probiotics
it feeds the oil okay that's something
you know that's why
i was totally gonna say if you have a
sibo or something and
already growing like you don't want to
feed you don't want to take prebiotics
because it will feed the bad bacteria
too
so if you're trying to get rid of that
like because you have a disorder or
whatever
don't take free bathrooms like what what
which foods have prebiotics
uh i don't know if they have three wise
already oh [ __ ] why you cannot
i just take the pill form oh yeah oh
true you know what a postbiotic is
postbiotic yeah
poop fast food
postbiotic really is your hat just a
velcro and you could change out what
goes on there yeah
it's from mercenaries like i fight for
russia i fight for america
i fight for it i don't have anything yet
to per
what would you put on it what would you
put on that uh whatever country's easy
yeah yeah if i'm in america i should get
a mushroom one so i could just put one
here
oh or you could get a here for the vibe
one and i will
on sale now next provost this is a
straight-up promo video
dude this is great dude you don't have
anything on your sweater yeah this is
nothing get a nike jacket at nike.com
they sponsor you no i wish bart for zero
percent off
you have your barbell shirt on
brigade.com
and you can get clothes and hoodies and
supplements all kinds of cool stuff like
nike let me just cover up this shirt
barbell barbell see the nike
got costco underwear too oh kirkland
right they're comfortable
they're the kirkland makes the best of
everything they make good chicken stock
they make everything really good so we
have ice cream
that'll be mine i'm gonna choose a
sponsor for you girls do you guys have a
guy
underwear that turns you on like boxers
or boxer briefs or bikini briefs or
thongs or
anything i'll answer this it's boxer
briefs yes boxer bracelet sex because
that's what i like
that's what the girls would like as well
we have very similar tastes
why why do you like box of briefs you
know honestly steve's the first
boyfriend i dated that wore boxer briefs
and what did they wear before that like
the the boyfriend for him
no no nothing that one commando
everywhere
the boyfriend before him just wore
boxers is commando not sexy because then
i'm thinking like from a guy thinking
about girls going comment i'm like
that's pretty sexy it sounds like i'm
just visualizing your balls getting all
mangled in your jeans
i go commando if my shorts or what i'm
wearing feels really good and better
than my underwear
yeah that makes sense true sometimes
shorts
inside they feel like fleece yeah do you
think that's why
when guys wear the gray sweatpants you
could see the dick prints better because
they probably did not
yeah oh cause it's soft maybe
who's going commando that regularly
though that's what i want
i mean her ex my ex-boyfriend who has
the confidence that like
their pants won't fall like that's like
hipsters and actors i think they do that
kind of stuff
yeah why do actors not wear underwear
what that's a thing
i don't know you'll see like these
paparazzi pics of like crimson's head
chris hemsworth and he's bent over in a
little butt cracker
which underwear butt cracks still show
what the boxer briefs steve's butt crack
shows all the time
interesting is butt crack a attractive
thing for
for you girls or not so much because
then like for me i'm like i think of
like
overweight plumbers we're on the same
way what do you think
it depends how hairy it is well i just i
don't think it would ever be a turn on
i think it's silly it's like a silly
thing
like how high i see your butt cracking a
[ __ ] butt crack
you were just like oh
soaked right away i think i speak i
think i could speak for all women when i
say that they really like [ __ ] stamps
on guys
yeah that drives them wild it's just
because like when we're we're having sex
from behind like we like to see the
[ __ ] stamp on the guy
yeah pegging is it when they're pegging
a dude you know i mean do you guys find
girl butt crack sexy like when you bend
over and see it
uh it depends on the girl but it's not
the girl yeah
i'm not really seeing that much blood
cracking in general you know we're
trying
the thong triangle that peeks on the top
triangle
yeah yeah the whale tail me and steve
got similar eyeballs
um you come from the same generation
because
like way back in the 90s and like early
2000s it was like super sexy to see like
the [ __ ]
like it up and they would have it really
high they'd have really because they had
low rise jeans
where now like it's high waisted is in
but before it was like down here i'm so
glad high waisted as well
well now it's like the reverse part of
the butt to see like now you want to see
the bottom of the butt cheeks
cheeks like right now from the bottom of
the shorts that's true because back then
i don't think that was a thing
i think that's sexier than butter same
yeah yeah
i like bottom of the butt cheeks it's
nice i think back then though it was
like
worse like worse as in like um not as
acceptable
yeah it was about showing off your
stomach back then that's why
i know it was a thing too oh yeah i
don't have a good stomach so i didn't
like that trend
same and then the low rise jeans i feel
like it gave me a muffin top
yes like it's like created an indent
from like all the low-rise jeans i would
wear
you like guys that were low-rise jeans
oh yeah like legend crevice oh seeing
that v is really hot
low-rise jeans is that when it's um the
button's lower
yeah like the whole thing is lower and
then like this pelvic bone part is like
above where the belt
see that part's hot but when they used
to wear it underneath their butt
i don't get that i don't get that trend
i did actually find that attractive at
one point really
what was attractive about it i think it
depends on where you wrote the whole
package
i needed to have a bald head white teeth
that a baggy pants socks that go
upstairs white socks that goes in here
yeah cortez's and oh man how would i
fare if i rocked that look
oh please shaved head you're out
immediately there was a period in time
where it was like
all guys i knew wore boxers and then
basketball shorts over the boxes and
then jeans over there
was hot back then and then i remember
one time like i didn't have clean
basketball shorts and i felt
naked just going boxers straight to
jeans yeah you know that [ __ ] leave
the house because you're always ready
for a pickup game
i guess you could drop your pants and go
well that's how it really would be
though like yeah like at my high school
that's
everybody had at uh basketball shorts
under their jeans
doing balls like that doc like it was
just baggy the pants were yeah
you needed them to keep them up or your
[ __ ] would be showing your ass crack
would be sean
such a weird trend my uh buddies in the
bay would
they would get rubber bands and then for
their jeans wrap it around
their ankles yeah yeah and i was like
damn that's crazy
i never seen that i forgot that's part
of the package too the rubber bands yeah
rubber bands
ultra had a weird sense of attraction no
so it was either
i mean it was just like that's like
that's how they would do it like they
would just dress up like that so if they
were wearing shorts then they'd have the
socks up here but if they were wearing
pants
then they would have the rubber band
like at the ankle and then they would
also stuff socks
yeah for what is it the chucks like the
chuck shoes yeah
those are the ones that they would like
that was like the whole guy fat game
i feel like wearing that you're like the
least compatible for
action like no you can't do anything
you couldn't run very far it was pretty
funny watching guys run
and pop fences and get caught in the
fans right because then i feel like
when you're wearing clothes like that
that's also means like you're somewhat
gang affiliated and then your backpack's
down here too is when you're running the
back yeah
or or it's really high it's either
really low or it's all the way up and
there's nothing in the background
the backpack is this big it's like
scrunched up yeah and then even the
shirts being tucked
up too so all you see is like butt and
then you see
and the dude gets under the butt and the
dudes that would sag
if they were to run they have to have
both their hands on their jeans yeah
like they have they have to be holding
them
or they're going to be at their ankles
oh and then they had wallet chains too
yeah see i think while the chain should
make a comeback
if you listen to the limbs yeah yeah
yeah there's masks
yeah what yeah they're very convenient
there's actually really cute ones
really i got like a chain like a dog
chain they have all kinds they have ones
that look like jewelry like a glasses
kind of chain
and then they have like hardcore like
big old chunky ones
like it's it's getting blingy yeah
interesting and
should we all get some well today's
video is brought to you by
care of baby and earlier we were talking
about how
bart can't answer anything over two
why's
no supplements probiotics prebiotics
vitamins all these things i think uh
we're all kind of getting into it
because we all are getting into our
health we're trying to be more
careful of all of this for me i um i
actually take a lot of vitamins and
supplements because i'm always like
experimenting with myself to see what is
the optimal way
of recovery and health and so we
partnered up with care
and they have this really cool like
five-minute online quiz
and i'm kind of tired of
creating my own cocktail of vitamins i
just want one place to kind of get
all of it done instead of me just going
and like finding
ashwagandha here and rhodesia there you
know
and seeing how much i need to take but
basically they go
they customize based off of your needs
and it's like a five minute online quiz
that i took it was super easy they ask
you questions on your diet your
lifestyle your health concerns and all
that and then they
basically create it specifically
tailored for you
yes if you're wondering care of is a
wellness brand that makes it easy to
maintain your health goals with a
customized
vitamin plan that helps you feel your
best today and supports you
long term and all of their products are
formulated
with good for you clean ingredients that
are backed by science and like joe said
you just take a quiz
and they figure you out so as the
seasons change it's important to get
ahead of taking care of your immune
health and it takes about 30 days for
your body to adapt to
new nutrients that's good to know so now
is a good time to update your vitamin
and wellness routines to help support
your immune system
this fall and the upcoming winter so for
your first
uh you can get 50 off your first care of
order go to takecareof.com and enter the
code
off the record 50. that's 50 off super
good deal
go to takecareof.com and enter the code
off the record
5-0 thank you thank you very much
i'll be i'm actually really into um
supplements right now like it's my thing
what do you think what's your stack okay
so i have
a crazy routine because you know i have
like a whole bag of probiotics
and um i i already eat like a lot of
foods that have probiotics like kimchi
like pickled
stuff you know sauerkraut yeah yeah
but you got to get the ones that um
they're not like manufactured at some
factory
made cheap it'll say on the label like
it has these probiotics or whatever
because the old school style of making
it
is like that's what ferments it for real
and then there's
but now like they just to manufacture a
cheap they just put vinegar in something
and they pickle it apple cider vinegar
that has the mother
the mother yeah the mother the mother
like uh
that's the alien [ __ ] oh you mean the
mother probiotic and then it's all like
yeah it like it like makes all the other
it makes all the like um like like
sourdough the mother nature
yeah yeah i know that from brooklyn it
just is
it's just the brags the one that
everyone gets and then there's just i
see some on the bottom but no it's not
the mother one
i like yak cult yeah that's how you say
it i don't know i know
i mean i grew up saying that but i don't
know how to look around
i grew up saying it yeah do you ever
make your own kombucha
no but my buddy vince's wife does and
she hooks us up
the scoob there's like it's like the
mother the mother yeah
they match i can't get past two wives
but
i saw one person do it one time i know a
lot
i'm like a ocean that's like an inch
deep
i know a little bit about a lot of
things but not a lot about a little
things
but didn't you have to study all that
when you were developing your own pro
uh that stuff i did yeah but i'm also
very good at forgetting stuff oh yeah so
like outside
i dive like [ __ ] head deep into some
[ __ ] and i and like you know we're
developing our whole like supplement
line for barbell
like i got really into things and then
as soon as i'm done i'm like i just
forget and i don't even know
yeah i'm the same way so i created a
routine and then like i am taking zinc
magnesium and all these other things and
then like
with carob like i'm gonna try this too
but then now i forgot why
i'm just doing it yeah and i know i feel
great so i'm not interested in lifestyle
that's a complete lifestyle it's like
you don't have to know why you're doing
no more you're having to integrate it
and so
it's like it becomes like breathing yeah
yeah that's arguably more important than
anything else
yeah oh my gosh speaking of of habits i
was telling casey about
that book that you yeah that we talked
about atomic habits by james clear
oh that's a good book yeah it's comic
habit what's so atomic about it another
book that i forgot but
like atomic level where it just comes
naturally okay that's
and like one percent changes over time
compounded into like
a better version of yourself okay now i
remember what it is that's sick
yeah because i just explained it
it's like i read the book and i forget
it
do you go back to books and reread it
yeah try to see it i really like it
yeah but i needed to wait for a year i
made a vow that i would read at least a
book a month
since i was 18 years old because i was
like well i'm not going to college but
i'm going to do continued education so
a book a month at least so i calculated
it the other day don't do the math on my
age
but it's around 200 books wow i
definitely read more than a book a month
are you only reading um
like what kind like non-fiction fiction
oh just
non-fiction no okay uh so do you own
that many books
i don't i don't because i did the marie
condo thing two years ago and
and she has you get rid of all the books
that was the hardest thing to let go
because it was like years and years of
cooks
i donated them
after you read it don't you feel like
you earned it yes so now i'm like
it's like a trophy oh yeah but that's
what marie kondo says
uh advises against which is a [ __ ] but
you don't watch your mouth bro don't you
ever say that about her
you take a picture she's a saint yeah
yeah don't you ever think marie condo
could be wrong
about her philosophy in some maybe
because sometimes i miss those books
because it they did bring me joy
three books and those three books i keep
forever well if you only have three
well three books three little bears
it's called goldilocks different version
you get a different version hungry cat
big red dog yeah
for the big red dog yeah and then and
who's your mama
and they're all propping up a coffee
table right now he's not even using it
to read
coasters do you guys ever do this where
you like go on this
book shopping spree because you just yes
you're gonna [ __ ] do it right
and then now you got like 12 books and
you're like [ __ ]
and then you'll read one and then you're
like but i gotta read this other one and
then you're simultaneously reading 12
books at once you do that wow
yeah i can't that's too much i used to
read
a book from page to page and like really
dive deep and write notes and things
like that yeah
but now i'm starting to see the
redundancy in certain topics with
certain authors
so if it's like the same author and then
they're
because they're writing with the
intention of they don't know who this
person is
and so there's like half of the book is
basically information
yeah it's like auditioning for the
audience and yeah building rapport make
sure that they know that you're on the
same
value system i skim a lot now and i try
to find something that
might be a new discovery for me that's
actually really helpful because
um repetition is what gets it ingrained
in your brain so now you don't have to
think you just know those things on
those subjects
that's yeah maybe yeah maybe you should
shouldn't skim you should read the whole
thing and then you'll be ingrained in
your brain
i do the notes thing get audio books
that usually helps
yeah like i've been fast-forwarding so i
just hear it as a chipmunk but yeah
three times speed but it's so slow like
do you guys watch podcasts at
regular speed now i can't do it anymore
oh for reals
it's so [ __ ] slow dude yeah i do
normal speeds
me too i'm just driving and listening it
drives me crazy
because when people are like um yes
well yeah in my opinion that's so boring
i think
it is the best who are you listening to
but people speak like that
yeah not everyone speaks like
you know like they're on jk news and
they could just keep everybody i feel
like there's preferences where i'm like
i just can't listen to
people that talk too slow but if you
just what if you want the information
though
okay i guess if they're like a very
respectable person that i really want
that information
but then i have to go into it like
eckhart tolle speaks so [ __ ] slow
but i have to like i have to prep my my
like okay
he's the author of the power of now
power of noun awakening
and he speaks slow yes he talks like
he's an asmr
it's meant to be slow like i wouldn't
speed him up because it's not about the
information but it's about the vibe that
you get while listening to yeah
the delivery and the the emotion behind
how he's saying certain things
sometimes hits harder than then yeah you
just get the information like so he must
be
really smart yeah he must be very he's
very wise
yeah yeah see that's what it is he's
calming is he's like mr asmr
yeah and i'm into that i'm super
interesting oh if you watch his q a's i
watch his q a sometimes
he takes forever to start answering the
question so someone asked a question
they'll be like define evil he goes
yeah is it because he's too smart like
elon musk where it's like there's
literally
a million answers what is the best
answer for this simple 10 in front of me
i feel like he
just is so present yeah that he just
like
isn't in a rush because it's not even
like he's fidgeting like for me if i was
waiting that long i'd be like you know
damn but he just goes
to define evil yeah that's dope you need
to
yes that means he's very thoughtful
yeah so he's not gonna say nonsense to
you he's gonna he's gonna say what it
really means he's on his own time
yeah yeah because time doesn't exist in
the in the now
and then now time doesn't exist and
suffering doesn't exist in the now
i got a reason anxiety doesn't exist and
then any acceptance of the moment
yeah that fool's wasting my time
you